here's Tom Hiddleston auditioning for
Thor and remember you chose this oh yeah
that's Tom Hiddleston's Thor audition
from 10 years ago and all I have to say
is Wow
and remember you chose this yep as it
turns out Tom auditioned to play thorne
of course that role went to Chris
Hemsworth while Tom landed the parts of
Loki at loss of a common sense I thought
you liked tricks now this magical video
aired while Tom was a guest on The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon where he
also offered up some backstory basically
at the time they were what they were
looking for sort of less well
established actors so that the audience
didn't have an association they were
like they just wanted people to see
these new characters these new actors in
the pan and I they would bait the remit
wise if you're over six-foot and you've
got blond hair and you know you couldn't
come and have a pop at it so I actually
or just I never auditioned for Loki I
only ever auditioned for Thor she's not
and while the audience went nuts for Tom
he did have this to say really are too
kind
III think we can all agree that they
cast the right actor of course et was
with Tom back in 2012 where he talked
about how much he loved playing Loki
it's one of the great characters I've
ever played he's such a it's such as an
actor there's so much meat on the bone
you know he's because it cos he's got
all this psychological depth and and
also he's just completely mentally off
the grid
he's not wrong tom has now played loki
in six different Avengers movies I'm
impressed
oh and there's more Loki on the way Tom
is getting a Loki TV series on Disney
plus you're getting your own show
unbelievable this is giant the next one
I didn't expect to be cast it at all
so I can't believe I've got my own show
so exciting well I am excited and before
I let you go I feel like we should watch
this audition one last time and remember
you chose this for it gets better every
time alright guys that's it for today
for all the latest on Tom and all things
Disney and Avengers keep it locked to
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and bye for now
[Music]